cette sélection masculine de martinique
de football va évoluer
le nouveau manager général frédéric iott
souhaite développement professionnel
évolué notamment liqueur française le
staff technique dirigé par mario bocaly
espère présenter l'équipe peut être
compétitive lors des éliminatoires pour
la gold cup
on va essayer de chat potté est
d'entourer toute la sélection de faire
en sorte que la sélection et les
meilleurs moyens on va pas dire
financier mais aussi humain et matériel
pour que pour qu'on puisse travailler
dans de très bonnes conditions et je
suis là pour que justement à partir de
france à avoir les meilleures choses
pour la sélection cette première séance
d'entraînement s'est déroulée dans une
bonne ambiance au stade puis à des
guerres elle a été marquée par des
enchaînements avec ballon pour le groupe
l'objectif où nous c'est de commencer à
avoir quels sont les joueurs qui seront
absolument à défendre les couleurs de la
martinique pour cette qualification à la
gold cup mais aussi pour la ligue des
nations je crois que c'est une nouvelle
compétition on va essayer de
s'apprivoiser cette compétition là du
tout au tout au long de notre
préparation qui on a jusqu'en septembre
pour se préparer
on va essayer de donner un petit peu le
maximum pour pouvoir avoir de bons
résultats et surtout faire en sorte que
la martinique sélection de la matanie
carrière la gueule comme deux ronds
coupe pas par moi pour cette sélection
masculine de martinique de football sa
montée en puissance à commencer pour
l'opération qualification gold cup 2019